there of course it is increasing talk
about how and when the lockdown could be
eased we'll be talking to the foreign
secretary Dominick Rob about the
government plans later but first we can
go to Devon where we can hear from a
medical expert the former deputy chief
medical officer Gina Radford who since
leaving that role last year has become a
vicar now of course we all know that
really the only long-term way out of the
lockdown
look at the lock down is a vaccine or
effective treatment how optimistic are
you that that can be found and how long
do you think it could take well I think
we need to be quite realistic about this
firstly we haven't at the moment got a
vaccine so we're having to start from
scratch we don't have a hugely good
track record with vaccines for this
particular virus coronavirus the family
of viruses but having said that
everything is being thrown at it there
are researchers all over the world
trying to identify back scenes so we've
never seen anything like the effort
that's being put to discover this
vaccine but even if we begin as we have
to identify things that might possibly
work vaccines that have potential and
there's also the huge process of testing
for there firstly whether they are
effective but also whether they're safe
because there's no point developing a
vaccine that actually is then going to
cause more harm than it's trying to
prevent though you know I think those
who are very used to the process of
developing vaccine are saying that
they're not anticipating is being
available until well into next year but
having said that with fast-tracking the
government's fast-tracking some testing
for example from Oxford so you never
know if that is successful maybe it'll
be with us sooner but then of course
we've got to manufacture it so you know
in the millions capacity certainly not a
quick process then as you say and now
I'm came to the auto pinion on a report
in the middle of Sunday today as well
saying that some British scientists have
developed these new immunity tests that
the ministers have ordered 50 million
off that could be ready in June these
are the tests that would effectively
show whether you've already had covered
19 and if you
to immunity do you think that sounds
realistic well we there are tests
already ailable and one of the issues is
not whether you know not that there
aren't tests available is actually how
accurate they are and so public health
England already been testing some and
what we call antibody tests and
unfortunately quality control measures
are not such that they are reliable so
whether this test is more reliable we
will have to see but the other issue we
need to put this whole question of
immunity in a little bit of perspective
we don't yet have evidence strong
evidence if you've had corona virus this
particular strain you are immune to
getting it again we don't know
you know what levels of the immunity of
antibody response are required and how
long the antibodies stay in the body so
we really don't know a lot about what it
means if you we do find antibodies in
people how long that's going to last so
that's why the government have set up
another research program to monitor a
large number of people over a long time
to see what happens to the antibodies in
their body it seems like a pretty
critical missing jigsaw piece that and
certainly listen to what you say it does
fellas have to lock down or some
measures of social distancing will be
here for a long time to come now of
course I know that what measures to ease
and when is a political decision but
would you be able to shadow make any
light on the kind of things that the
government is likely to be weighing on
well firstly whatever happens I
anticipate that the lockdown will be
lifted in two stages is not going to be
suddenly everyone's back to normal and I
think the message is getting through to
people that for many of us we're illness
for the longer term
but that they'll be looking at firstly
what's actually going on in the rest of
Europe from the rest of the world who
are ahead of us in terms of the epidemic
curve and we've seen for example that
what tends to happen is things like
small businesses being opened first if
they can safely socially distance
I'm social distancing is the key so
whether we would look at different types
of business maybe also different parts
of the country and also things like
schools we whether we can let children
go back but in a very safe way so maybe
reducing the numbers in a class maybe
having some classes going back one week
and other class going back another week
and they and their schooling being
supplemented by the continuing of online
classes so I think that the key message
is that whatever happens this is going
to be a staged process certainly
actually say be really important to look
at other countries and learn from the
lessons that we see there if you do look
around the world you can see that
certain countries seem to have done
frankly much better I guess and the UK
in being prepared for pandemic such as
the one we're seeing perhaps countries
like South Korea for example who have
experienced these respiratory pandemics
before but at the same time we've seen
what's happened with MERS and SARS even
if we didn't experience them so much
in the United Kingdom why was it that we
weren't better prepared for this why
didn't we stop Palmore PPE why don't we
invest in capacity for more testing why
don't we look down earlier what's the
answer
the answer is that all these things are
a balance aren't they because if you
stockpile masses and masses of PPE
firstly everything has an expiry date
let's be quite clear and also you need
the capacity to actually store this and
you then need the logic it's
underpinning that that means that you
can then deliver it and we know at the
beginning of this pandemic there were
some issues with actually even
delivering the stockpiles that we did
have the other issue is the difference
with this particular pandemic is not so
much that it is a pandemic it's awful as
that it it's actually the deadliness of
this virus so other and you know the
other sort of pandemics we tend to be
used to in this country like flu etc it
has not been as deadly as this one and
that is why it is caused such
an appropriately strong response from
what countries globally and put us into
lockdown so you know I thinking did
summarize we usually you know we do have
a strong track record of being prepared
for pandemics but this is a pandemic of
a completely different wave now just
finally while we've got you and you know
Vic a pretty big career change from
deputy chief medical officer during a
lockdown we've seen Christian celebrates
Easter Muslims Ramadan how difficult is
it for people of faith to acknowledge
these festivals in really difficult
times of social social distancing what
would your message be to them I think
the most important thing is to remember
that you know at the end of the day our
faith is central to who we are and we
celebrate and worship together in
whatever way we do but we can now
through the wonders and innovative and
creative ways that we are finding
worship and celebrate perhaps through
that the means of technology or the
phone or different ways that all of us
have a personal faith as well as a
communal faith and the most important in
all of this and all our faiths would say
this is that we have a responsibility
for each other we have a responsibility
to ensure that our own actions don't put
others at risk but certainly in my own
parish it's just been wonderful to see
the really creative and innovative ways
we've had a worshipping we have Xoom
services we have telephone services we
have zoom coffee mornings we come
together still as a community and also
the other important thing is the
pastoral side so people of all faiths
are coming together to show that support
to the wider community in very very
practical ways whether it be through
food banks that are helping with
distribution of food parcels and
medicines we all as people of faith have
a role to play in that